/ me quiz is to that we're interested in
now first wave a plus B or swear it's a
perfect square it's a biodome you
multiplied by itself and everfeel
squared
what'd it look like it gonna look like
this right
that's actually drawn quickly I drew a
square what did your square because it's
a perfect when I'm told it a and B a and
B and so I have this ring some bells
right three bells only job a what's this
one here a square what's this one down
to the bottom is where and then one of
these two pieces both what this one
agency and this one's big I'm a from do
right which is why is the result you
recognize a squared plus how many abs
two of them plus B squared okay in much
the same way you recognize that a minus
B squared is going to be the only thing
that changes is the to a B in the middle
okay now how do you prove to yourself
that that is true how could you do it
it's justice square a minus B and then
another bracket just write it like this
is that what you're suggesting wouldn't
you something that'd be a plus a minus B
a minus B oh yeah yeah so you can't just
do just like we did before and you can
expand your chest out and when you see
if we do now how to read and read again
you see this is going to give us ones
that pay gonna give us it's very good
what about this table carefully
you've got to watch that side right - a
B then I can do these
- a B again but look at this time the
last one double negative so that's why
it's a lot are you happy with that
yeah okay right now that's all you need
to recognize two squares so for example
let's any color now again physically for
example if I showed you three X minus 1
all squared this is a perfect square
which one is it more like top a bottom
bottom subtraction right so I'm going to
write that add the first one squared
this whole thing 3x what happens when
you take the whole thing and square it
very good so you square both of those
pieces
well what okay there's a - is that it
will be a - they're two times each of
these things you put them together two
times each of these things 3 X 1 that's
just 3 XE is that ok I'll simplify that
interview what there's nothing in what
is great that's a plus sorry
it's a monkey okay the B in this case is
1 so I've got a B squared over there so
I'm writing a 1 squared down here all
the Duke right now just to tidy up that
middle term minus 6x plus 1 are you
happy with that
okay now when you look at that it's just
as important to be able to recognize and
this is harder we said this before this
have a look you need to be able to give
back words remember we did a standing in
factorizing yesterday and I said
expanding the easy factor I the entire
when you look at this I don't know if
you immediately think that I don't it
takes some practice to get that but
that's when we're going to get you to by
having a look at these frequent when you
recognize oh I think that's a square I
think I can work with that
okay I need a bit more space but
underneath another is underneath perfect
well I want you to write anyone want to
guess it's another kind of vibe
difference of squares now I promise this
is a long time I'm going to ask you to
do it today I love the way that you just
came down with a picture just like we
did it before
can someone tell me what pair of
binomials I know you do I put together
to make difference of squares so you
want to remember anyone else are saying
so what it is the waves usually written
is a minus B and a plus B oh please
by the way we made a fancy name for
these things before insert do you
remember when you got the same pieces
but they're different by a sign in the
middle it's not to the seat there
remember the cold hot close they're
called conjugates we would ask questions
what did equal to so that's been on the
right-hand side I've been on the right
hand side is where it gets the name
difference of squares right that's a
square that's a square you take a raw
egg you'll get the difference okay I
love this one let's draw what this
diagram for this will look like I want
you to look at this thing over here this
thing over here how would you go see
first second before I do it hmm hey
people I'm going to do it I want you can
wonder if you can follow this to me I
know it's not beautiful but I wonder if
you can imagine and see that this is a
way to draw a square minus B Square can
you see how it is where where the A's on
this divert this and this right in there
both a then the whole shape if I
this bit here as well the whole shape
would be a sweat okay so we're gonna
make this done a lot recently
okay so that makes this B times B are
you happy with that we make a different
different no one look
[Music]
okay now here's the really fun bit and
the tricky bit yet the secret husband is
this is what we've just drawn stay with
it because it will flash by them in a
second that thing on the right is what
I've drawn so my question to you is
where are these over here this is what
we saw where are these on this diagram
now one of them is easy to spot and one
of them is hard
can anyone spot either of them can you
see if you live where there's a minus B
or a plus B those what do you reckon
ejected on the way
okay why speak with Karen right what do
you think she really is okay where is
they wait a second Jake Ryan just said
something helpful for about harvesting
catcher Ryan would you do so kind of to
sanity so on the ball outside you've got
a whole length of a but then you've got
to be changing our Vic
yep can you see that so this is a right
we could say over there that's a but
you've taken away big when you go back
up to here so this thing over here it's
a - bit you agree you with me now I
wanted to take off you can see a nice
female idea side-by-side but that's only
half the picture with a plus B where is
it
top of eight Hey what's not wet this
what this is a isn't it then one of the
other day isn't that also a minus B okay
all right
here's I need I need to concentrate
really hard for this next moment so need
require still waiting for my roller
thing okay I need you to take a pair of
scissors in your wand
okay a paris's okay you got it there we
know Paris is what I want you to do is I
want you to cut along there okay
can you imagine taking this kind of you
spin huh and just sort of going off to
one side okay now if you've got this as
one piece remember that a - B what's
this leaf over me and banana so what I
want you to do is now that you cut that
off is I want you to pick that up and I
want you to move with it down over here
did you take this or pick it up and move
it over here you can country because
look you did a bit of a minus B over
here it should sit against a minus B
over keep your grass I've had to chat
again later turn okay so now this is
like irritable you've moved it around do
you see it yeah what's this length again
very good so what is this new rectangle
a coffee right Hey
[Music]